there's a lot to look forward to at the
box office in the coming year from
superhero action thrillers to
down-to-earth dramas and everything in
between here are all the movies that
will blow you away in 2019 M night
Shyamalan continues his surprise
superhero trilogy with glass a sequel to
2017 split whose final act unexpectedly
tied in with 2000's unbreakable the
movie will bring back all the main
players from both films with bruce
willis samuel l.jackson James McAvoy and
Anya Taylor joy all confirmed a return
as revealed in the first trailer the
story also involves a psychiatrist
played by Sarah Paulsen who observes the
three men in an institution while
probing their delusions of grandeur
speaking with vulture Shyamalan
described glass as a story about the
struggle between doubt versus belief
given Shabalin love of twists they're
certainly more to glass than we know but
this is a story nearly 20 years in the
making so we're sure the director knows
what he's doing
glass is slated to arrive in theaters on
January 18th Marvel's first female led
superhero film will be long overdue when
it hits theaters on March 9th 2019 but
the movie is shaping up to be worth the
wait
for one thing Captain Marvel has Oscar
winner brie Larson as Carol Danvers and
Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige has
said she'll be quote as powerful a
character as we've ever put in a movie
the studio has directors Anna Boden and
Ryan Fleck at the helm for an origin
story for Carol all of which should help
sow the seeds for Marvel's phase for
storylines while setting up a new hero
who's sure to be a key component of the
fight against Thanos and Avengers 4 as
if that weren't enough the film's first
trailer makes it clear that we can
expect plenty of space action and more
than a few laughs 2019 is going to be a
good year for horror and a good year for
Stephen King in addition to it chapter 2
the year will also see the release of
Pet Sematary based on Stephen King's
1983 novel about a family that moves in
next to a burial ground with disturbing
powers that proved too difficult to
resist the book was previously adapted
for the big screen in 1989 but the
newest version of Pet Sematary has some
horror visionaries on board in directors
Kevin Kolsch and Dennis wittmeyer who
previously worked on starry eyes as well
as episodes of MTV's
screen TV series Jason Clarke is
attached to the role of dr. Lewis Creed
first played by Dale Midkiff in the 1989
Pet Sematary film joining Clark for the
remake is Amy Simons as Louis's wife
Rachel and John Lithgow who is set to
portray the Creed's neighbor Jud
Crandall who knows all the dark secrets
of the animal burial site after which
the movie is titled with an experienced
crew and a stellar cast locked in place
not to mention a suitably freaky first
trailer Pet Sematary should make for a
spooky Easter weekend when it premieres
April 5th
Shazam has been a long time in the
making but the DC Comics movie is
currently slated to finally hit theaters
on April 5th 2019 the movie finally
found a star in October 2017 in Chuck's
Zachary Levi who will play the grown-up
superhero that teen Billy Batson is able
to turn into when he utters the magic
word okay Shazam the movies first
trailer made a splash at Comic Con by
making it clear it'll bring a different
tone to the DC Universe its premise
means it is sure to be a bit more
ridiculous and humorous than DC's past
movies and the young hero should allow
for the mix of fantastical and real-life
problems that have served superhero
films well in the past while Black Adam
won't appear now that he's getting his
own standalone movie the film has
recruited a scary villain and Mark
Strong who is rumored to be playing dr.
sivana Shazam's arch-nemesis have you
ever noticed how in Hollywood movies all
the villains are played by Prince
maybe we just sound right the
behind-the-scenes crew also hints at a
different DC film than we've seen before
with Jack the giant slayer 'he's Darren
Lemke attached to work on the script and
lights outs
David F Sandberg set to direct to shoot
David Harbor will unveil his new take on
Hellboy on April 12 2019 with the
stranger thing star joining director
Neil Marshall for what's been described
as a gritty take on the classic Mike man
Yola comics Harbor has said the movie
will use a darker tone to differentiate
itself from Guillermo del Toro's
adaptations adding it'll be more of a
character piece while harbors take on
Hellboy looks spot-on the rest of the
cast is also packed with potential
including Milla Jovovich as the
villainous blood queen sasha Lane as
Alice Monahan and ian mcshane as Hellboy
his adopted father
maybe he'll teach young Hellboy a few
combat moves get ready to meet your
maker never underestimate your opponent
the fourth Avengers film will mark the
end of Marvel's phase 3 which means it's
probably time to break out your tissues
the current set of films is coming to an
end and many of the big-name contracts
are expiring as well I'm doing what has
to be done to stave off something worse
you keep telling yourself that
in other words Avengers 4 will probably
result in quite a few character deaths
with Iron Man Captain America Thor and
more all likely to bite the dust with
the no-holds-barred approach the studio
will likely have to the film Avengers 4
is sure to be epic ending dozens of
storylines set up in past films while
also placing the framework for what's to
come in the franchise's future this is
definitely one of the can't-miss
adventures of the year it arrives on May
3rd Keanu Reeves animal-loving hitman is
coming back to theaters on May 17th 2019
for John wick chapter 3 the film will
see wick going on the run with a 14
million dollar contract for his head
having broken the rules and taken a life
on the grounds of the Continental Hotel
wick finds that he's being targeted on
all sides the crime
the killer for hire should already be
long dead but he's given a chance to
escape by the Continentals manager
Winston who grants him a one hour grace
period before his membership is revoked
he's banned from all services and he's
cut off from the other members wick
turns to the service industry to stay
alive as he fights his way out of New
York City in this third installment
which is directed by the previous films
sheds to hell ski of course we're pretty
sure there's only one way it can all end
Oh kill the Godzilla king of the
monsters is the follow-up to the
well-received 2014 film featuring the
monster and brings in a largely
overhauled roster of stars with stranger
things Milly Bobby Brown the conjuring
'he's Vera Farmiga and Friday Night
Lights Kyle Chandler playing a family
swept up in the trouble the monster
causes with the impressive cast Godzilla
king of the monsters should be able to
live up to the positive reviews of the
original while providing more big-screen
monster mayhem as the first trailer
indicates the big green guy can expect a
lot of company in this installment and
it isn't necessarily of the friendly
variety either look for it on May 31st
Tom Hollands spider-man is set to
continue his adventures in a second
standalone film on July 5th 2019 which
will follow another year of Peters high
school experience the first movie was
wildly successful with both critics and
fans and the second is bringing back a
lot of the elements that contributed to
its greatness including director John
watts who's working from a script by
homecoming co-writers Jonathan Goldstein
and John Francis Daley despite all the
returning names in the film's crew
spider-man far from home will be far
from the same movie
the sequel takes our friendly
neighborhood spider to Europe over
summer vacation which happens after both
Avengers infinity war and Avengers 4
according to Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige hopefully that means a big
return for Spidey and Avengers 4 or
he'll need some extra help getting
around
Pennywise will make his terrifying
return to the big screen in September
2019 yet chapter 2 is set to hit
theaters almost exactly two years after
the first film which followed the lives
of a group of children known as the
losers club as they dealt with the
advances of a shape-shifting evil
the sequel will move to the present
showing the adult versions of the
characters as they return to the town of
Derry to deal with Pennywise Azaria
mergence director Andy muschietti is set
to return for the sequel alongside
screenwriter Gary Doberman the first
films massive box office haul and
critical acclaim meant it was easy to
land big-name stars to play the adult
losers with Jessica Chastain James
McAvoy Bill Hader Jay Ryan and James
ransom set to appear the movies child
actors will likely return as well with
muschietti saying there will be dialog
between timelines whose caddy has also
said that he would like the second film
to explore the cosmic dimension of the
novel dealing with some of its
otherworldly aspects sign us up no joke
two standalone films featuring Gotham
City's most infamous tormentor are being
produced in 2019 and one could even get
released before the end of the year
Variety reported in June 2018 that Jared
Leto's DC EU Joker is getting his own
movie but it's still unknown if it will
film before or after the upcoming
Suicide Squad sequel set to go into
production in 2019 and then there's the
wild card a joker
origin movie outside the DCE you
starring acting powerhouse joaquin
phoenix is now under way this means
there's a chance this reportedly darker
and more experimental take on Batman's
iconic arch-nemesis directed by The
Hangover Saad Phillips could make it
into theaters in October 2019 Werner
brothers describes the script co-written
by Phillips and Academy Award nominee
Scott silver as a gritty character study
but also a broader cautionary tale
sounds like no laughing matter
Bharath in some shake ups behind the
scenes of Star Wars Episode nine with
Lucasfilm dropping Jurassic world helm
or Colin Trevorrow a few months before
production was set to begin they found
someone who's definitely qualified to
take over however with the force awakens
JJ Abrams returning to write and direct
the trilogy finale episode 9 will
provide a resolution to the Skywalker
saga while setting up a future of
standalone movies and spin-offs meaning
that while we're undoubtedly in for the
final appearances of some classic
characters this chapter will also serve
as a launching pad for years of the
franchise
future it's set to hit theaters in
December 2019
[Music]